sí muy buenas tardes pues lo cierto es
que en este discurso digamos que él
resumió rápidamente todos los diferentes
anuncios que en realidad se vinieron
haciendo a lo largo de toda esta jornada
en los cuatro segmentos diferentes en
los que se dividió toda esta mañana de
charlas en las que escuchamos no
solamente a macrón sino en realidad a
los varios jefes de estado y
representantes de más de 40 países aquí
presentes en esta cumbre en hambre est
tal vez de lo más importante que dijo
macrón en este en estas últimas palabras
de cierre es lo que tiene que ver con la
gobernanza de los océanos en especial de
esas aguas internacionales esas que no
están bajo jurisdicción a nacionales
como ustedes se lo pudieron escuchar
pues hablaba precisamente la necesidad
de lograr un acuerdo un acuerdo
internacional un acuerdo universal que
sea vinculante pero este así como él lo
lo lo dijo y también como se puede
entender a lo largo de todas estas
jornadas que va a tomar tiempo hay que
lograr convencer a todos
el mayor número de países para que
puedan participar para que firmen en
esto por eso él hablaba de varias citas
internacionales a lo largo de todo este
año 2022 para trabajar en pro de ese de
ese acuerdo una de esas citas va a ser
el próximo mes de marzo en la ciudad de
nueva york en una reunión que va a haber
en la onu en torno a los océanos y luego
también estará la reunión en o portugal
y más adelante ya también la con 27
hacia final de año pero precisamente
pues ese tema de la gobernanza es el más
importante porque es allí donde como les
comentábamos hace unos instantes pues es
también donde se producen un sinnúmero
de actividades ilegales no solamente de
explotación y sobreexplotación
del océano de las riquezas que haya allí
riquezas marinas y pues la idea también
es esto para poder proteger el océano
que finalmente digamos que fue ahí tiene
dos particularidades por una parte es
víctima del calentamiento global y al
mismo tiempo el mismo es una herramienta
fundamental para luchar contra esto